no I think um I think man I just you
know salute to you dog because I swear
man I always tell people that in
interviews whenever your name is brought
up I'm like man you're like I think like
a beaming light from a city that needs
that light you know what I'm saying and
I think um
you know just to watch you I think the
first time I saw you I was on the side
of the stage at Summer Jam when Nikki
brought you out yeah that's crazy so
that was like 2014 or 15. was that 14
2014 for sure how old were you 2014 I
was 17. so that was yeah I remember that
[ __ ] like that was like that was one of
them days 14 17 18 some [ __ ] like that
yeah that was one of those days I always
remember because we were right there
like we bullshitted our way where the
label didn't kick us out and I'm like
standing there watching [ __ ] Nikki
and Drake yeah and you get brought out
that was a that was how big of how
pivotal of like a day was that for you
to get brought out of Summer Jam by
Nikki man that [ __ ] was crazy bro I was
so nervous I couldn't even really like
because you got to understand bro I'm
coming from
say knife every day that's why I'm
hanging it like literally I'm right
there the day before I fly out the
ground so it's like I didn't even feel
like I belonged there right I feel like
I felt I'll Blended in better over there
and that's the wrong way to think cause
I've been a superstar [ __ ] I wouldn't
even been there if I ain't belong with
it of course Nikki would have never
reached out to me if I didn't deserve to
be there but when I come around that I
feel like I was out of place that's
[ __ ] crazy I should have felt like I
was out of place on my block right you
feel me I felt the most comfortable over
there and when I get around Wayne
[ __ ] baby Nikki all these Superstars
me this is my first time really meeting
all of them right I ain't say a word
yeah Drake was there bro Drake [ __ ] I
swear to God Drake could contest to this
right now yeah we backstage
my first real encounter with Drake was
y'all don't know who this is this is my
favorite rapper Drake called me his
favorite rapper [ __ ] when I was 18.
it's my favorite rapper right now and I
got so shy I'm like man what the [ __ ] he
just put me on the spot like that for it
[ __ ] me up cause I felt out of place
already being there I didn't feel like a
stop you know I'm so I didn't know how
to feel like the stock cause I'm up
against this [ __ ] you're up against real
life I'm up against real life yeah I
didn't feel like a star bro so for Drake
to tell me that right then I didn't even
know how to feel it made me so [ __ ]
uncomfortable that he did that you feel
me and that's probably why like our
relationship ain't with should be today
because I didn't Embrace him telling me
that yeah I didn't know how to feel when
he told me that [ __ ] bro I swear to God
a [ __ ] told me in front of baby Wayne
Nikki G robot that night that night
backstage he said I don't know what this
is cause I'm in the corner I ain't
talking to nobody right right right I
don't know this is man this this is my
favorite rapper man right now I'll [ __ ]
with Shorty and I ain't know what to
think I still was nervous when I went
out on stage you feel me like yeah and
I'm saying all that to say for any
artist or anybody that's trying to do
this [ __ ] like embrace your inner stock
embrace your power because this [ __ ]
could be taken from you any day and I'm
blessed that God didn't take this [ __ ]
from me when I took it for granted or
when I didn't understand what it was and
that's why I'm here today you know what
I'm saying so that [ __ ] crazy to me bro
is crazy and that full circle you came
out of rolling glasses I came out
rolling loud with Nikki you know I'm
saying like full circle to this day me
and Dre cool that's my brother yeah I
talked to him all the time so I'm saying
like I was will you be hooping together
and [ __ ] now you feel me we go hang out
and all this [ __ ] you know like so it's
just like a different horror that I have
about myself because I'm mature and I'm
a different person